2 1 un autre dynamitage en plein coeur
du mont royal
en un peu plus d'un an voici l'immense
trou qui a été creusée sur le campus de
l'université de montréal
la future station édouard montpetit du
rem sera la plus profonde au canada
alors nous sommes dans le monde chargés
on s'apprête à descendre à une
profondeur de la plongée dans le puits
principal est impressionnante
ici quand la station sera terminé 5
ascenseur transporteront les passagers
des qui jusqu'à la surface
en 25 ans une station qui est un
chantier enfin deux grands chantiers
comme on va retrouver dans le grand nord
du québec au niveau des mais nous au
niveau des chantiers hydroélectriques
m'étais construit en plein coeur d'une
ville qui est densément étudier si on
est dans la maison principale de ces dix
derniers mètres pour atteindre le tunnel
seront excavés à partir de janvier quand
les trains vers de montagne ou mascouche
ne passeront plus aujourd'hui à peu près
deux trains qui sont présents en même
temps dans tunnel mont-royal
tandis qu'avec le raymond parle de dix
trains qui vont être les systèmes
électriques l'éclairage et la
ventilation à améliorer un mur
séparateur à construire au milieu
beaucoup de travail en vue bref qui
aurait même amené le constructeur à
douter de sa capacité de rouvrir le
tunnel comme prévue en 2022
mais la caisse de dépôt grande
responsable du projet continue d'être
confiante
les chantiers en fait ce sont en avance
sur les chiens c'est donc on est très
confiant pour 22 pour le secteur ici 20
21 pour la rive sud
une fois le tunnel ou vers les branches
vers deux montagnes sainte anne de
bellevue et vers l'aéroport de dorval
devrait quant à elle être inaugurée en
2023 ici jean sébastien l'outil radio
canada montréal